[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: If you haven't done
so already, set up your project
and create a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
In the Cloud Console, on
the Project Selector page,
select or create
a Cloud project.
Make sure that billing is
enabled for your Google Cloud
project.
Learn how to confirm billing
is enabled for your project
in the links below.
Enable the Cloud Vision API.
Now create a Cloud Storage
bucket in the Cloud Console.
Go to the Cloud
Storage browser page.
Click Create Bucket.
Assign a unique bucket name.
Do not include sensitive
information in the bucket name,
because the bucket namespace
is global and publicly visible.
Select the location where the
bucket data will be stored.
For default storage
class, select Standard.
Then, click Create.
Now you can make requests
via the Vision API.
Download this demo
image linked below.
Open the Cloud Console
storage browser.
Select the bucket
you just created.
Click Upload Files, and select
the demo image JPEG file
to upload from
your local machine
to your Cloud Storage bucket.
After the file is
uploaded and listed
in the Cloud Storage browser,
share the image publicly.
Open the interactive API
Explorer template found
in the guide linked below.
Complete the
template by replacing
cloud-samples-data/vision in the
image dot source dot imageUri
field with the name of the
Cloud Storage bucket where you
uploaded the demo
image dot JPEG file.
Click Execute to send the
request to the service.
The JSON response appears here.
Congratulations.
You've just made your first
images annotate request
to the Cloud Vision API service.
To learn more about
specific features,
see example annotations,
and get annotations
for an individual file
or image, check out
the Cloud documentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]